- [Narrator] In late October,
workers in China lined up for quarantine.
Then others rushed to leave
their jobs and some clashed
with police in COVID protective suits.
(crowd shouting)
These are images of the chaos
that erupted at a Foxconn site
in Zhengzhou, China
where the majority of
Apple's iPhones are made.
Now holiday shoppers this
Christmas season are stuck
with long wait times,
and Apple warned its Pro model shipments
would be lower than expected.
(protestor speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] So here's what
led to the protest at Foxconn
and what that means for your iPhone.
(camera snapping)
In late September, the travel season
for China's week-long
National Day holiday began
and people hit the road.
When residents returned from
other parts of the country,
that's when COVID-19 broke out Zhengzhou.
The virus eventually spread
to Foxconn's vast manufacturing site
where the company enforced
strict COVID controls.
(worker speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] By late October,
some workers were sent
to quarantine centers.
Others were confined
to unfinished apartment buildings nearby,
and they were filmed
screaming in frustration.
(workers shouting)
Meanwhile, some employees
were asked to move out
of their dorms and sleep
in the factory hallways
to keep production running.
Worried about catching COVID,
on October 29th, thousands
of workers fled the facility.
Some people boarded buses
after hearing rumors
that infected employees
were being allowed to work
to meet production goals.
(clock ticking)
To replace those who left,
recruitment ads started
popping up on November 7th.
These ads promised quarantine
allowances and bonuses
for people who would
work for 30 or 60 days.
(protestor speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] But things came
to a head on November 23rd
when new recruits got angry
over what they said were
delayed bonus payments
and conditions at the plant.
(crowd shouting)
To control the outrage,
police were deployed,
beating and chasing workers.
The next day, many employees
lined up at a train station
after taking up Foxconn's
offer of $1,400 to leave.
The company also said it
would guarantee recruits
would be paid in line with official ads
and blamed a computer error
for some of the pay issues.
The staff shortage has added pressure
to the tech giant's iPhone production
as Foxconn Zhengzhou facility makes 85%
of the Pro line up of iPhones.
This means customers who
ordered their smartphones
in October or November may not
even get it before Christmas.
To see why, take a look at this graph.
When Apple launched the
iPhone 14 Pro in September,
the wait time was 32 days
during the first week.
Then it started to decrease.
This is pretty typical
when there's a new launch
like with the iPhone 13 Pro.
But when COVID hit the
Zhengzhou plant in October,
the wait time went up and
eventually hit 37 days
by late November, which is the longest
in the product's 15-year history.
Apple didn't respond to a request
for comment about the iPhone delays.
Meanwhile, steps are being taken
to mitigate the ripple
effects of the disruptions.
Foxconn has tried to
increase iPhone 14 production
at other sites in the country,
according to people
familiar with the matter.
China's rigid COVID controls,
among other issues have
also prompted Apple to look
beyond the mainland, particularly
in India and Vietnam.
And this could mean in the
future many of our iPhones
start coming not from China
but from other countries.